ashley and i are sexual people we like
having sex with people we like choosing
a different stuff than i am but um
we both like like masturbate a lot
she has no more butt stuff like butt
fingering than i am
i think i enjoy like sucking dick more
she's in the morning
[Applause]
and sistine stallone we just become best
friends yup
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine stallone and it's gonna be so
interesting when we cut it and your
glasses just suddenly disappeared from
your head
magic in new york
conk you can't you were just singing it
with me with sophia i heard my voice
after i sang it and i realized it was so
good it was good when we're together
that's true
you guys
i'm feeling a little bit
buzzed yeah the city is giving me energy
sophia and i have a new york state of
mind it's great we took unwax to the big
apple people the big crunchy apple
that's where we are right now i am so
excited i just saw lady liberty out the
window this is incredible i saw bridges
i've seen way too many um high towers
with high towers skylines you got am i
close she got it you can tell we're from
here i swear i'm smarter than this um
but this is so exciting because i
don't remember the last time we've ever
done work in new york for me i haven't
worked in new york for a couple years i
mean obviously coveted and everything
but it's so exciting to be here for like
a purpose oh it's very exciting sophia
and i have been planning this work trip
for about two months now yeah we have
incredible guests coming on oh my god
you guys the next few weeks are going to
be stacked so much fun so stacked
today's guest is actually
insane that they're coming on our show
yeah i am pretty surprised that they
said yes to this because they really
know how they're oh geez they're oh
jesus this is they are us
but
way more famous and
way more of a following and they've just
like completely dominated this podcast
industry so you're telling me they're
basically us but just not the walmart
version yes they're the uh we're the
discount prices we're the bait leg we're
the bootleg they're like the elise one
okay let's talk about being here we've
been here for about four or five days
now yeah how are you feeling being in
the city i love it honestly i love the
change of pace because i'm not used to
this type of art you lived here for a
year so i i didn't really i haven't
acclimated that much but i love being
able to walk everywhere i think that's
just the beauty that's part of
everything and also you can just go to
restaurants anytime everyone's out and
drinking everyone's it's so it's also
it's also different the city is
different when you're with your
boyfriend
and i kind of just thought of it you're
kind of like a little housewife you know
what i had last night sophie and i went
out to dinner with her boyfriend and i
go to his apartment i meet them there he
comes home from work and sophia runs
over like a giddy school girl he's like
maybe i missed you so much and i was
like well it's literally like a
housewife yeah okay you love it i love
it it's so fine well like because i
don't know we know we're doing long
distances so anytime i get to see him
it's like the first time as seen sitting
there going hello the background
no but it's fine i and then you have to
stay with scarlett right now yes i can't
keep that girl in a leaf she's running
amongst oh she told me her goal was to
find the best
bagel a bacon egg and cheese bagel she's
had four bagels in two days yeah she
figured out which one's the best so do
you guys know we need some good like new
york rex by the way okay
that
is what i need
i've realized that i'm so
not a new yorker and i'm trying really
hard to sort of fit in have the attitude
have the walk the hustle and bustle when
i'm getting by but you can just tell i
stick out like a sore thumb well i'm
trying to acclimate and turn into a new
yorker because i don't want to be that
person you can completely tell the
difference between someone that's from
new york oh yeah and someone that is us
not from new york so i see one trend is
walking across the street not looking
both ways i was gonna say this
whether it's saying to go or knock out
people just don't care and there's
something i've seen so many almost
accidents happen and so i'm thinking in
my head okay i guess this is kind of
like the rite of passage to new york
yeah
i can't tell you how many times mom
would be so mad knowing this i almost
got hit by bicyclists that's one of the
worst ones by the way you would and taxi
drivers i've gotten honked out a few
times because i'm one of those people
you got to just do it i can't hesitate
i'm in the middle of the street and i
hesitate and they're like okay if you're
gonna just cut me off just like finish
the process of it and i uh sofia goes
just finish me if you're gonna hit me
hate me why don't you but yeah no that's
probably that's how you can tell that
i'm not from here because while everyone
is jaywalking and there are no cars
coming either way i actually wait for
the crosswalk to allow me like i'm
waiting there like a good girl like i'm
gonna wait like a dodo yeah i'm also
outdoors because i'm like let me go
check out times square
yeah also i hate that place sorry uh
it's disgusting not my place i saw a rat
i saw a rat yesterday i saw the naked
cowboy
i actually
did a photo shoot with the naked cowboy
a photo shoot this sounds weird all
right there's this guy in times square
he's one of those people that you pay
five bucks can take a photo with him
he's basically a cowboy with long hair
and a speedo and he paints his body and
it says naked cows he has a guitar and
he plays guitar right so i was doing a
shoot years ago and they said sistine go
take a photo with the naked cowboy and
he put it all over social media i was so
embarrassed you're like this is the best
moment ever i know it's like i am single
well now he really just got the stamp of
new york on you once that happened no i
know i know it was years ago when you
came here right i like it so much better
now i i figured it out
yeah well you were older well you're
older now how old were you when you were
living here i was a wee 19 year old so
that's the thing i feel like it's so
it's a very different experience of
maybe i'm wrong but when you're 21 or 20
versus or not 20 but like 21 and up
versus 19. there's a lot more things you
can do nightlife wise but i guess do you
want to see a show or is that touristy
no i i love broadway there's no visual
show business
i love rock i've seen wicked probably
we have seen wicked 14 times at least
actually no realistic number was
probably nine times which is a lot it's
still a lot it's a lot that's not even
counting how many times we've seen
phantom of the opera which is at least
six legally blonde mamma mia mean girls
book of mormon oh yeah i mean dear evan
hansen yeah yeah yeah i actually would
love to see a show you would oh yeah i
was about to go to a show in l.a there's
uh there's that theater that's on pretty
woman
what show are you trying to see
it was uh there was no right now pretty
woman's not out until june but tootsie
is on tootsie yeah what's tootsie you've
never seen tootsie
no oh it's a it's like off of a movie
and then it's it's good it's a guy that
can't make it in hollywood and so he
dresses like a woman to and pretends
that he's this great older actress and
it's really funny i was watching the
trail i'm like i gotta see this i almost
went by myself because i was so bored i
was alone i was alone last week
completely sistine was gone boyfriend's
gone everyone's gone and i was like do i
just go to a show alone yeah go down
tootsie
i was but i think it's gonna be gone by
the time i get back you know what i
would love to do we should surprise your
boyfriend and bring him to a drag show
how fun would that be uh yeah
but i've always wanted to see a
dragstrip i don't know how like crazy
that would be he would love it yeah yeah
he'd think it's like so funny why not
yeah why not we can do that do you know
where one is no
uh well other than that i actually think
the food is great here too
i was really against new york food i'll
be honest and everyone was saying no new
york has the best food
i'll tell you what's overrated joe's
pizza
don't like it sorry everyone seems to
love it hot take
it's not that good i've never had it
i still haven't had it is that the
artichoke pizza
i can't just drop it
what i you lived here another overrated
levine bakery
if you like those cookies i'll see you
haven't had that either i need to go to
all of these are you kidding me no give
me give me an hour
we're gonna eat three hours i'm gonna
eat my way through the city i gotta just
do that i know i'm an idiot i go to the
places that go to l.a like joe and the
juice there's like four next to me in
l.a yeah and i decided to go to that in
new york out of everything i could have
gone to you know what we should talk
about i'm a creature of habit if you
haven't noticed our parents just
celebrated their 25th
anniversary 25. it's always how old i am
that's how i know because i was born
before they were married she was a
bastard
i was at their wedding a little bastard
i was jealous i was the star of the show
no it's been 25 years which is wild yeah
wow you think of that
if you can find someone and be with them
for 25 years
good on ya really romantic they
celebrated their 25th year anniversary
sophia actually came up with a wonderful
idea that they should get remarried in
vegas yeah so what they did for one of
their um just renewals they went to
vegas with my mom's sister and her
husband and like a friend and they got
hitched my mom was wearing this white
crop top so hot and she looked awesome
low rising she was still in and they
just got hitched with uh elvis and i was
thinking they got to do that again but
we as the children i think it's our
responsibility yeah no to plan it oh
yeah you don't want to fly and jenna
getting on a plane to go to vegas no we
have to plan it a little time i mean yes
it will it be hot in vegas at summer
time yeah
but will it be the best time ever yes
and so i think that once there's a
conditioning i said i want to do that
let's let's do it no but i'll tell you
would you want to get hitched to vegas
kind of like what courtney and travis
kind of but things i like that idea i
think it'd be fun to get married before
the actual wedding and not tell anybody
that's what i want i don't think i would
like that oh sorry i would do it if i
was older you're not invited i would do
it if i was older i think if i was
younger your first wedding is so sacred
i say first money like i'm going to have
three more
um the first one has to be special the
second one is vegas for sure um but i'll
tell you what 25 years of marriage looks
like i witness one of the dumbest
marital fights that i have to share and
i was like wow this is what it's like to
be in a long-term relationship
this is going to make me not want to get
married no it's actually really funny
how stupid it is so
my mom has this giant bag of cookies
delicious she actually got them from
walmart
doesn't matter they were so good right
so she goes back into the kitchen
looking for her cookies
and they've disappeared and she goes sly
where did you and there were at least 45
cookies in there no where did you put
the cookies he goes i didn't touch him i
didn't touch your cookies i didn't touch
them right she goes i know you did they
were sitting here 20 minutes ago where
did you put them right after him denying
it for 10 minutes he goes up to his
bathroom
pulls them out of his bathroom trash can
right half eaten like there's probably
three or four left at this point and he
throws them on the table and she goes
you threw away my cookies why and he
goes because i couldn't stop eating them
so he threw him away my mom goes you
know what sly i'm throwing away your
biscotti and takes all of his cookies
and throws him in the dress oh my god
that was so
funny funny because i've never seen mom
get so mad about a cookie she was like
what she goes because you don't have
self-control and you can't stop eating
away the things i like exactly no i
think it's so funny that dad is just in
denial doesn't want to admit that he
couldn't stop eating the cookies no and
he was so embarrassed he ran away with
his tail between his legs it was the
[ __ ]
epic this is love this is love that's
true love i'm fighting for walmart
cookies i i agree right what are you and
uh
you're done i'm talking about this okay
we're gonna move on
so we're so excited because today we
have
we were kind of building them up in the
beginning we got girls gotta eat on our
show
uh
huge they are so funny they just are
what we said before us but we're the
walmart version they just give it about
boys sex dating um just life in general
moving like everything that they say
has so much comedic flair to it and i am
just so excited to see what conversation
comes out of our mouths it's no but it's
also really cool to have
other
i wouldn't say we're comedians but
another comic podcast host girl yeah
sitting with us it's really inspiring
sophie and i listened to them even
before we talked about you know starting
our own show yeah now they're
top charts of
all comedy podcasts and itunes i mean
they're killing it so we cannot wait to
talk about everything so stay tuned
[Music]
you guys so we could not be more
thrilled today to have all these
hilarious ladies and i've been listening
to them and so has sustained since
literally day one i think when you guys
walked in i kind of just are you serious
oh no no you have no idea
no seriously we've been freaking out and
i've been obsessed with your podcast um
they're the hosts of the comedic podcast
called girls gotta eat great name gge
and they discuss sex dating
relationships all everything in between
yes this is reyna and ashley
no it's actually true the other day i
went on spotify and i clicked on your
podcast and i said oldest to newest
right and i watched like the shirt's
dead and i was like oh my god 2018 i was
really in it with you guys
oh my god i don't even know what we've
said back then who i don't know who we
were isn't it kind of funny because
we've been doing this for over a year
and there's so much stuff i've said in
the past i'm like what why did i say
that or like did anyone remember that i
did this or said this or i don't even
know our new information you just walk
some stuff back we all deserve to learn
new information i love it well your
guys's podcast has truly taken so many
forms and shapes i mean not only you're
successful on the audio format you have
merch you're going on tour it's like you
guys are
constantly
tomorrow
yeah we go on tour
glamorous tour in detroit indianapolis
and pittsburgh
[Applause]
like the states yeah best place to go
wait so how long is your tour well we
just
we always we're just kind of always on
tour like we don't leave on like a tour
bus
like a musical artist would do we just
kind of go out come home go out come
home like we'll go do california come
back you know we don't want to be away
so your suitcase is always packed
yeah it's i think i also have a suitcase
on the floor from like a month ago yeah
but just keep it out we want to have a
life so it's like important to us to
like be here be home actually as a dog
obviously friends we're trying to get
laid part
and stuff like how do you go out and
date if you're like completely gone
twenty-five [ __ ] on the road a lot oh
okay perfect that's the thing
do you [ __ ] fans
ashley did but
you're going into gen z people yeah
there's a lot of stigma around like
having sex with a fan but i look at it
like
you're having someone that really likes
your
fan girl energy is not hot let's get it
let's get it clear i did [ __ ] a guy that
came to the show but like he did he came
with like his girlfriend who was a fan
girl girlfriend sorry
female friend oh he was a huge fan yeah
we had a threesome it was amazing um no
but yeah it's if someone was like
fangirling i wouldn't really be into it
right but i want someone to like what we
do but what if they're
i met this guy because i actually
thought he was so cute like i wasn't
trying to sleep with him he was in
california i just thought he was so cute
i put him on my instagram story and i
tagged him yeah you fangirled him i
thought about him yeah that is that he
loves him and then he responded to my
instagram story oh my god wait i'm such
a huge fan of the podcast and i was like
no you're not you're twice that's hot
now we're mutual fans of each other yeah
i like cause you you guys both like each
other's work and i think pudding
we're calling it that yeah putting
yourself out there like that is such a
power move and it works and i think
girls a lot are really afraid to do that
because i saw
you know you guys put one of you posted
a very steamy like thirst trap on
instagram i travel probably right now
yeah i saw it it was right now it was
your back and like you're a little bit
of your butt and i was like did it work
are you first trapping someone in
specifics
so i will say most of mine and ashley's
fans are female like not fans but like
most of my followers
are lucky not a lot of like weird creepy
guys we're 16 up or that definitely
probably yeah
why ever would that be no
i don't like it but i think people are
like also like used to me doing it i
feel like i got to do it less a little
bit now cause people it's starting to
like not have the same effect again yeah
right maybe like some people again yeah
they're like desensitized
this whole thing of tagging someone and
hoping that it like starts the
conversation yeah i tried it recently it
did not work i just oh no i've been like
kind of
this guy might have a girlfriend but i'd
kind of like
i don't i don't know him but i like his
content i think he's funny so i like
reposted something he didn't tagged him
and he just reposted and say anything oh
but he so she has a girlfriend
oh she's a fan
that's so confident
you're right i went i failed him and he
was like it's not hot see that sofia and
i always say that the best way to sort
of slide in or get a guy's attention is
not going directly to the dm but respond
to a story specifically like do you guys
have any tips that always sort of work
or catch the eye yeah i i did that um
one time there was this guy that i did
not realize who was following me and
these this like one of my followers
message she was like oh my god ashley
this guy is like so hot he's so big on
tick tock you gotta like i can't believe
he's following you so i was like let me
check him out see what he's about and he
was like very cute and so
i just waited until he posted a story
that i could like flirt too
it took like it was like a long game
i was like that's my move that's like
the one specific one that makes sense
for you and it was it was like a
valentine's day like and i got right in
there and we started chatting and it
didn't work out but we started texting
we had like a phone date once like one
of our shows i love that i ended up like
getting it going yeah and that that
totally was the move like the story so
what are your guys's relationship
statuses currently we're both single um
we've dated like a lot throughout the
winter um i had a thing with that
tic-tac-eye for a minute and uh
we said we were trying to get into wifed
up winter and that didn't help out i
love that it was a cold season she has a
boy
that happened she got into winter yeah
she actually did it's true actually it
wasn't
sorry set them up so i'm like at least
something worked out yeah yeah yeah you
know the single now dyed my hair black
we're going through it we are going
through don't get bangs and we're going
to be fine
it was the color of the bangs no i have
a tip for you there's clip-on bags just
feel them out you're so right how you
feel about banging no one's doing a
clip-off
just don't cut the table
by the way
i've ordered two pairs of clippers
i will show you my amazon receipt she's
doing clip-on bags but they don't match
so they don't not work
they're just like a light brown mama's
like a strawberry blonde
black
it just looks like blonde bangs with
like dark brown hair like a sistine it
just doesn't work this color is so good
that's cute
i mean i guess it's black is it just
dark brown like it's a kardashian yeah i
was going through megan fox and i'm
getting like adam's family a little bit
no no no no but without makeup it's a
little spooky
when you're in a breakup mode because
that just happens all the time have you
guys ever done that where you've just
changed i have never done like a crazy
hair post but like i i feel like we all
have those
urges yeah and i am somehow able yes
because i like really want
i i don't want really dark hair i want
long hair like i'm just kind of i've had
those moments like should i just yeah
just do it yeah but i realized my face
is just not for short hair i feel like
i'm not built for it i tried it and then
i go to the freaking hair salon and they
cut off like more inches than you want
it and you're like but because you guys
are so busy and touring and working so
much do you even want to be in a
relationship i mean i go back and forth
it would be nice to have like
someone to talk to i mean i have
something to talk to i mean she's like
i'm not worried i mean i think that like
the most the primary thing ashley and i
say on our show always is like build a
life you're so proud of and have hobbies
and interests
your friends have got relationships with
your family so that like you don't need
a relationship yeah you know you want
one and they're a great addition to your
life and i was with somebody for about
eight or nine months and it was great
and he complimented my life really
nicely ashley he understood comedy i can
take it or leave it sort of right so i'm
really like proud of what we do for work
and our lives are so fun and we travel a
lot we have so many friends so yeah i
like to get [ __ ] down on the regular
like i'd like to [ __ ] more right but i
can sort of take it or leave it because
i feel like i have so much companionship
in my life yeah yeah i'm trying to build
out a roster um in every city
one of our guy friends was like i just
picture you with like a guy in every
city and he just is like wait in your
hotel room after the show you know what
you should do how's the show when you're
like take your picture you're like yeah
we should do like a draft pick for you
let's do a call for it honestly
no guys want this like i feel like they
do
i feel like they do you should have
someone like send in forms you choose
which one you like out of all the forms
then she just go on the date like if
you're like 5 10 or under i'm just gonna
take them i'm gonna put them in your
pile
you're like wait
a cute you love a short king i don't
love it
well i had one guy slip in that was five
nine but he actually slipped
he's a great face
is he funny he's really funny and cute
and he's a mustache do you feel like
people lose their personality the more
interested they are like higher taller
yeah i mean we think that
like you all rana says like if you're
a shorter guy you just have to try a
little harder you could be funnier you
know like what do you think the
equivalent for a woman is like if a
guy's short they have to try harder what
do you think it is oops
i mean no tits get a personality i don't
i don't think that's like i mean if
you're we're talking height i mean for
for me like i was like a tall awkward
you know middle school high schooler
like all the boys like so it kind of i
felt less desirable growing up so it did
make me kind of need to try to like be
funny i agree with that you know i would
say my equivalent is having abnormally
large feet where i could actually wear
their shoes as well so i'm like how do i
compensate they're like a ten and a half
eleven oh my god we're the same size
feet we could ski on our head meltdown
growing up because my feet were so
quickly and one time my dad took me shoe
shopping and like i had a meltdown on
the store and he came home and so it was
like i'm never shopping with her again
my mom was like you traumatized your dad
it was like
scary but you're right i never really
thought about it because you i like i i
was not the pretty girl growing up i was
fine i had big boobs i got a lot of
attention from right i didn't i wasn't
like i wasn't pretty like my friends i
never i mean i was cute but i didn't
feel pretty so i felt like i had to try
a little bit
we had awkward sages too for a while
when do you guys feel like you really
grew into yourself like last year 30.
okay wait actually that's actually a
good question that's yeah do you think
your 30s now are going to be better than
your 20s
yeah i mean i'm nearing the end of them
um no but
yeah i mean i
will i think i
am in my prime now right to me it just
keeps like getting better like i look
i think i look better than i did 10
years ago like i you know i felt like i
was like i look better at 35 than than
25 like i mean again it's a lot of it's
like i've had some work done you know
right we make more money you just kind
of start to put more money and you're
here yeah it's also confidence that you
get from your thirties that you don't
have
my mom said she just stopped giving a
[ __ ] yeah what other people thought and
then that honestly exuded this sort of
energy and this aura then you just felt
better about yourself than other people
looked at you that same way yeah i think
you like figure it out i think like
your 20s you don't know what the [ __ ]
yeah i think and then you are like
figuring it out in your 30s and
i i think that you know what you hear is
like 40s is like no [ __ ] right
it's like by the time you're like that
must be in 90s 60s you're just like
getting tattoos you really don't care
you're going all over for me i've just
i've always known that there's always
going to be other girls in the room that
are hotter smarter cooler more
interesting whatever herb but that
doesn't make me less any of those things
right
i think i'm [ __ ] cool and interesting
and fun and i think i'm sexy and i can
[ __ ] well and right if you don't think
that then that's fine like i'm just not
your girl that's that's fine too like
not every man is going to be for me
either i need that mindset 24 7. you
guys are like this is why you're so good
at your own podcast which is what i
would love to get into girls got to eat
first of all the name
i love it because it's really up for
interpretation people always ask us what
does unwaxed even mean i'm like whatever
you want it to be what does girls gotta
eat mean to you guys
i could define it
like
it it i mean i i came up with it i
remember i was like walking around the
city and like texting reyna ideas like
she was like veto i like this yeah right
and
so to me it was like this open-toe
interpretation thing i mean i think you
can
interpret it literally and like girls
got to eat girls got to get a free meal
go on a bad date you know what i mean
or i mean literally we eat all the time
like so much of our random was a food
blogger before we started the show and i
think you can also interpret it like
a girl's got to get her he's got to get
laid gotta do whatever or get her bag or
like whatever it is like i think it's
just like
it's just a
fun name that you can interpret however
there's not that much deeper than it i
mean i thought of it from a marketing
standpoint honestly too gge you know
yeah sounds great it looks great on
merch we call our listeners snacks which
is like so great it looks cute
yeah gge is like such like an easy thing
that like rolls off the tongue so yeah
ashley came up with it the show was her
concept um we met on an influencer trip
in aruba on the beach it's off really
wait explain
wow
we both had these big instagram accounts
and yeah it's gonna get
invited i haven't been invited to aruba
yet i'm sure you guys go on your own
you know you're past that point
i think it was what the marriott invited
us on this influencer trip and just
people for like big followings they
wanted us to like live blog it basically
yeah yeah and um ashley and i were just
seated across from each other at this
dinner and we got to talking and it's
funny this really good friend of mine
ended up missing the flight and i
usually sort of like spend a lot of time
with him like in the corner because he's
a little more quiet but he didn't come
so it ended up being all these girls and
so i just stayed up all night with
ashley and we all talked about like
dating and relationships and our
breakups and she had had um a very
serious relationship in her life and and
i had one that was really horrible for
me and and we just bonded over it we
stayed up all night i was like this
girl's so [ __ ] controversial
we were trauma bonding it really doesn't
matter we have like an enemy that you
can both like go against perfect yeah i
love it i mean i had went into that trip
like
really [ __ ] up with something with my
ex like
one of them i mean we had broken up
before i had moved to new york but like
something had happened and i was just
like not okay and it was so crazy that i
got to that trip and i was like i felt
like i was in the verge of tears i was
and then i had to kind of have some
self-talk like ashley you're on this
free [ __ ] trip it's beautiful like
you know go out to the beach get your
[ __ ] together um and
like it was one of the darker times of
my life and then i like met raina and
which like changed the course of both of
our lives so you know what i mean so
it was so crazy and i like how we had
like
and i'd like had this intention bracelet
on to like whatever it's like so cheesy
but i like remember taking it off at the
end of that trip because i was like i
just feel like i'm like turning a corner
on some of this like stuff with my with
my relationship so and it really was you
know
so you guys really changed each other's
lives
we've told this story on sony shows yeah
i'm so emotional i love it and that's
true i mean your guys's lives changed
the moment you guys both played i mean
like it was just
have you guys ever talked about because
i have a pact with my best friend that
if we don't get married we're just going
to marry each other do you guys have
that same way we can't ever
you know oh no so we are like we spend
every moment together yeah we travel out
we have all the same friends and i'm
extremely close with ashley's family i
spent holidays with them traveling so
practically you're the side piece yes i
have that with a guy friend which i feel
like we're coming up on it
i think i think it was 40. which that's
very far off don't even question it um
but
a guy friend of mine his name's bobby
like we just said that
a while back
actually i think we had it we like bobby
i like him for you which is but if he
see i like neither one of us like truly
like i can't imagine dating somebody
that other people didn't like but if i
dated somebody that like didn't get
along with her it would be like oh big
time i can't even imagine have you ever
liked the same guy
not even for one second
not even for half a second i was very
that was funny
it's really i hate like competitive
energy with friends you know and so
one of the best things about us i feel
like you're i think it's like that's
probably a meme out there somewhere if
like best friends don't have the same
type you know you're never feeling
competitive that's true um but we have
this thing that we this guy that i
hooked up with at a show
he came up on stage and
i he was actually midway between both of
our types the way he looked like i was
like oh my god but she had had this
thing going on with the
tick tock guy
so it kind of deferred to me and i was
so happy because i feel like that would
have been a moment of like who gets him
yeah but interesting what would you have
done
i think i'm a little more aggressive
sexually on stage like i'm more likely
to like be like choke me spank me go
choke ashley so like i don't know
like what your tour is i might have
sucked my claws into him i don't know i
i honestly doesn't even give her an
opportunity it's just literally i really
think it's probably no you're not i'm
not quite so you guys choke on stage
where can i get tickets yeah girl
scottypodcast.com and we have a fall
tour i love that yeah whenever you guys
want to come to show you don't you don't
need 100 but that's actually a really
interesting point because
being competitive with a friend is
very common but especially when you are
in a work relationship because i know
sophia and i
getting into business together can be
really tricky if you don't navigate it
correctly
so we've had also 20 years right that's
true but has there ever been like a
moment with any of your business
ventures that you guys have done
together where
you know difference of opinions or
something didn't exactly click or you
guys have always been sort of on the
same page
um i mean i i think that
you we have such a
like wonderful working relationship so i
think we balance each other out like
really well i just think that we work
really well together and we've learned a
lot and how to just be better
partners um friends and
we almost always agree on big picture
stuff that's awesome
we realized we didn't know we ran and i
were friends for two months before we
like entered into business together so
it's really
where you guys were near each other in
new york no i was in brooklyn like 45
minutes really yeah it was just we hung
out like three times like it's not the
best friends that started a podcast
which is good because we don't know each
other's stories and so a lot of it is
like learning about each other
everybody's kind of been along for the
whole friendship but we didn't know that
much like when i think about luck i
think that's the luckiest part i think
that we work hard and we've you know had
uh you know
i just think that
the luckiest part is us getting along so
well because we always joke like what if
one of our goals was to like
be
on the bachelor and be a reality show
star or something like that like or like
turn this into something different so we
always have like the the
same same like long-term big picture
goals i love that yeah it's we really
did luck out i co-signed everything she
said and i mean we share a business bank
account we travel together the trust is
there we share an email address four and
a half years into this and like it's
just the division of work has been
really simple it's just sort of like
this feels like an ashley job this feels
like a rain a job we've hired some
really great people to love that it's
nice when you intuitively know who would
be better at what job because even for
us we have specific things that we can
focus on like i'm more of like the
analytical
more the kind i'm more she's more the
creative funny person she's like the
business one yeah with the concept it's
like it's not everybody know okay who to
lob it up to that actually can because
that's what makes a balanced team and
that's what makes sense successful what
are you guys what are your lives what do
you think they would look like if you
guys didn't actually meet yeah i can't
think about it because i i i moved to
new york in 2017. i was doing stand-up
and was doing are you still doing
stand-up yeah oh yeah so we need to get
into that and go on like a solo tour
yeah and that's another thing too right
now
rayna doesn't do stand up she's not
competitive with me like we're just not
competitive with each other you gotta
have your own thing yeah i think people
were a little like ashley released this
solo tour
and i think people were like what's so i
texted her in the morning do you want me
to promote this on my instagram right
right um or do you want to like need to
do this yourself and then all of our
friends promoted it and then it looked
like i wasn't promoting it like you were
like jealous i was like no i asked her
if she wanted me to do this
i was like everything's sold out you
don't need to no um yeah that too i mean
i just i think that
i guess
i guess some people are destined to make
it right i guess like the way that you
think about the world the way that you
know how to like pivot your brand and
work really hard and meet the right
people and network is like i have i have
that in me and rated us too but
it's i think about it sometimes like
what if we wouldn't have met you know
what if i would have started this with
someone else which i was thinking of
doing before i met reyna like
i have to sometimes i like think about
that like what if and it's like a scary
thought yeah you know i also before i
had actually i'd never been on a stage
before ashley and i have done like world
tour we've traveled everywhere we've
done it right 120 sold out live shows
i've never been on a stage before and
ashley's like vision for this was like i
want to do like a live show and live
podcasts were more like table reads at
this point right it was a lot more like
panel discussions you have a guest and
they sort of chitchat right we've i have
never i think we like invented this
format of this like grab bag show where
there's like so much going on now we
have yeah can you walk us through like
what one of your shows looks like
it is really so much ashley's brain
child like the live shows and how it's
grown and we say it's like the wildest
girls night out you're ever gonna have
like the videos the hype videos you see
are truly what they're like we have nfl
and nba dancers like open the shows in
every city yeah it's like a halftime
show it opens like a halftime show
and then there's like cryo jets like
steam and t-shirt cannons and like
strippers and like crazy stuff
yeah this is a bachelorette party
like it is honestly like a halftime show
a bachelorette party
have you had bachelorette please just go
to your house birthday parties
and it's just like such a cool night out
it's not just a comedy show it's so wild
and people really lean into it i mean
people just really want to like stand up
tell their stories get [ __ ] crazy
we've seen so many more men start to
come really couples i love that because
it was just like all women yeah right
but i am like so proud of it cause i
think about our first show
like in september of 2018 we were at
caroline's in new york city and now in
at the end of august but almost exactly
like four years to when we did this
we're gonna be at the met in philly and
like well not his ex is performing the
same month at that theater okay yeah
alicia keys i was like
i feel so proud of the growth and yeah
that gives me chills like that is just
yeah it's almost like you guys have
literally hit the top of the mountain
where do you go from here like what's
next i don't well our new business
yeah
let's just get into that i said he had a
new business yeah so we um
while it's like a two-part we're going
to only talk about the first part for
because we're kind of releasing them in
different uh different dates so but the
well we are launching a line of sex toys
the company is called vibes only that is
the best name yes
i don't know how no one's actually
thought of that before but it's actually
funny because it isn't just vibes only
there's a whole other part of it so it's
like that one night i laid awake i was
like was this a mistake because it's
more it's more than vibes but so we
brought you guys um yeah you just have a
bag one of those is the ashley and one
of those is the rayna and then there's
like which one does
like ones for
yeah there's three toys that we're
releasing and then we're gonna release
more we call them vibes not toys um one
of you guys arena and one of you has an
ashley you have a lube and you have a
[ __ ] gel
blow job gel what's that so that's the
ashes the ashley wand
beautiful rose gold handle
you guys are boss ones are great
and then in that okay if you open that
one that's the ring
stop
and it's you open it there's like a [ __ ]
sucker on one side and a vibrator on the
other
it's two-sided yeah oh i've seen it it's
a dual motor it's insane i have a
question okay blow drop gel so do you
just look at that
take it
away just make it more enjoyable for you
so i am like ashley and i
where do i even be in i love blow jobs
so much i love talking about blow jobs
do you like it because you know you're
good at it or is it because yeah it's
fun to do you're just like someone else
so i always blow jobs are like cyclical
like if you like it you're good at it if
you're good at it you like it like i
think that yeah
should be for you right i think that you
should enjoy it the [ __ ] gel is
a great thing because
oh my god that is delicious
where were you you were in a hotel in
seattle i was in a hotel instead it
sounds good actually this is delicious
i'd put this on a cocktail this is
something now
it's good
it's good it's good can you imagine i
like grab a guy's dick i'm like hi guys
welcome another episode of girls gotta
eat i am doing that
that is
my jokes in the bedroom don't always
totally fly like i had sex with this guy
the guy that i met on the road and like
it was like a journey to get to
whatever it's a long story but we
finally did it it was a great experience
and like after we were done
he like you know he had he'd come like
on me and i looked and looked up at him
and i said we did it joe and he stopped
he like
did it he literally was like what'd you
call me wait but i wanna i really wanna
get into that because i was like i just
killed it i was like mic drop moment how
funny am i i would have been a great if
he liked god if you had a slight sense
of humor it's hilarious
it's the post not clarity he had no idea
what was going on here
humor enough like he came to the show
like he you know what i mean but i think
in that moment it was like
she thinks my name is joe you know what
i mean
she's like he's gonna register because
we're wrong super fan wrong super fan
that is wait but so when you do stand up
do you think that guys get intimidated
because
there's a stigma with you everyone says
you should never date like a male
comedian like they'll ruin your life
does the same thing apply to women i'm
not in this
so i have a lot of thoughts on it and we
also recommend um we love this special
ali wong special where i love ali is
such a badass she's so good she's so
good and she talks kind of like about
female comedians first male comedians
brain and i do think that a lot of male
comedians will ruin your life and there
are a lot of like damaged male comedians
out there but there's also a bunch of
damaged male finance guys out there like
it doesn't agree agreed
women feel a little different it's not
it's kind of it's not the same
personality type of course it can be but
yeah i don't think it's that
it's not attractive to all guys like it
can be intimidating like i'm not
everyone's cup of tea right now like
where it feels a little different i
think that men are on stage they have a
mic in their hand they're making people
laugh like every woman in the room it's
like panties are dropping and guys are
like i don't want any part of that right
right you know but do you ever have guys
because we've had this situation before
like we use this kind of as a therapy
too whatever happens with our week
whoever we're dating whatever is
happening we get mentioned but you don't
say their name but we talk about the
situation and then they end up reaching
out and getting upset like have you guys
had that before you've like brought up
exes and they're like why i've had their
grandma tell me they listen
this isn't good i mean ashley and i i
think have always tried to be incredibly
respectful of the people that we date
especially i mean i'm not to like to my
own [ __ ] one of the biggest podcasts in
the united states yeah i'm not trying to
put something to that horn
i mean i don't know
the biggest show ever on our show right
now
we're not trying to like ruin anybody's
life we understand that people's like
families are co-workers especially
listen yeah so we're never trying to
like do something terrible and also like
we use each other as a check and like
you know ashley that's our show and
she'll say like do you feel like you
really want to say this thing on the
show
like i for example like went through a
breakup in the fall and like ashley and
i like
went through the talking points before
we recorded because i was like he's
gonna listen his family's gonna listen
um
we're always gonna meet guys that are
like you know not interested in dating
somebody so public yeah and that's fine
yeah have you guys gone through that yet
i don't think anything's so terrible i
mean people certainly ask me not to
discuss certain things on the show and
that's fine yeah you're like okay i mean
i
i'm not trying to like give myself a
pity party i think it's difficult i
don't think that people i don't think a
lot of guys want it i don't think they
but it doesn't matter like to me it's
like never
what's the alternative not doing this no
no
all right well someone will you know and
it's like
i am living my dream life like it's an
actual dream right you know there's
nobody's life i envy in terms of someone
that's like married and has a family you
know it's just like this is the life i
want this is so it's the the right
person will come we'll find each other
hopefully one day or not you know it's
whatever like live in a common mood for
all your best friends and a bunch of
dogs yeah and i have bodies
i think some people are more private
they don't want it but then i think the
right person is gonna really
like it you know i've dated guys that i
talk about them and they like can't wait
to listen yes you know right yeah right
absolutely i agree i co-signed
everything she said i'm like so excited
about my life and happy and the right
person will fit in or not but my ex was
fine about it he had a podcast so he
would talk about me on his show so our
show you liked it ashley and i do tend
to date people like in entertainment or
comedy because they'll play around they
understand it a little bit
also like we're on the road and i know
that you look at my instagram when i'm
on the road it looks like i'm on
instagram stories and [ __ ] around
having fun but like ashley and i work
all day we're on the road we're busy i
get off stage i'm not trying to call you
necessarily by the phone and somebody
needs to understand that that this is
always going to come first of course and
your friends that like because maybe
friends that aren't getting married or
going to a lot of bachelorette parties
or weddings or whatever have they ever
questioned you guys about the way you've
decided to shoot because i feel like
even our friends are like oh yeah like
we're ready to get married now it's
necessary
ages of 24 to 27 are engaged engaged
like my entire facebook i don't know if
it's like i said is it a rite of passage
to promote that you're
engaged or married on facebook because
no one uses it i don't use it anymore
but like sorry do you guys no no i don't
know if i just age myself no not um yeah
but do you guys ever have that and you
kind of have to counteract what they're
saying or like because i know that we
get that sometimes wait what do you mean
like in sense like because you guys are
not focused on like daddy there's always
a time limit for women i feel like when
they say oh you have to get married
before 30. there's like a body clock
half the dogs have the highest you know
i mean do we feel weird about it or do
people question it people question you
guys on that stuff like ever i mean we
did a whole episode on um not winning
children um because i've like never
wanted we literally just talked about
one in children yeah so yeah i mean
no i think that i don't know i feel like
maybe i've been lucky or i've just
surrounded myself with the right type of
people that are like you know support
she's gonna ashley you know i don't
really i think i was all my college
girlfriends got married 22 to 28. like i
was the last one i'm still not married
you know guys yeah um but i wanted to
ask you guys i want to go back to it
have you dated guys that don't want you
to talk about them oh absolutely oh yeah
actually i've had a lot of guys before
my boyfriend like he's he like doesn't
mind if i talk about but obviously not
in like very detailed things but it
really bugged me when guys before even
talking to me like getting to know me
they'd be like oh are you going to talk
about this on your podcast and it's like
side comments like that and i'm like
okay like i get the haha joke but if
you're really intimidating i mean it
could it could help in her i remember
one time you were dating this guy and
sophia you were quite blunt about the
moves that he wasn't making that you'd
like him to make and he listened and he
made the moves and it worked yeah so
we've done that sometimes it's kind of
like it works it does work i was like he
doesn't text me on time he doesn't do
this he doesn't do this and he literally
sent me this long apology going like i'm
so sorry i should have been but i think
you're right about the entertainment
when they're in that business they
understand it the people that had the
hardest time dealing with it were ones
that were like a completely different
field of work yeah yeah yeah and i i
most of the things that i say on the
show me personally i think if this
person was sitting in the room would
they have a problem with what i'm saying
listen you own your own story you have a
right to explain what happened in your
life you want to and none we're never
gonna have the same exact story as
another person but i want to get it as
close to possible close to right as
possible yeah yeah and if you're super
shitty to me i'm gonna talk about that
too i'm not gonna put you on blast by
saying your name but i'm not gonna not
talk about it yeah like we deserve to
let it out and i deserve it i mean i'm
talking to all my friends about it is my
friends these are our friends right
snacks are your friends and i think that
like
i don't think anyone wants to feel like
they're being used for content yeah you
know but like they're being used for the
bit um i think all comedians understand
like there was there's unspoken thing
like that it's going to be a bit you
know something happens but it's not that
i just i also feel like if i meet
somebody that i'm like this is feels
serious this feels like a like a real
match for me like i could see a
long-term future i would be more
cautious but right i go on a date or i
[ __ ] some dude on the road like what who
cares like that's not like again i
respect their privacy always i'm not
trying to you know put anyone on blast
but it's like
i don't
but this isn't someone i'm gonna be with
right by the way
you don't need anyone because you
created your own sex toys yeah so i mean
you're set for life named after us
literally named after you is so genius
you can have sex with anyone literally
anytime you ever leave the house you
have access so and then
again like we're there's more coming no
no
there's a whole other component of this
your your the vibe is going to get
better every single week
but i love you guys so sex positive i
mean it's just it's such it changes the
game and i think so many girls are in
the same book and they just don't know
how to express it and you guys are just
like pioneering it yeah i mean we talk
about masturbating i don't think that
we're the first people to ever talk
about masturbating and be sex positive
but like ashley and i are sexual people
we like having sex with people we like
choosing a different stuff than i am but
um
we both like
masturbate a lot
she doesn't know more about like butt
fingering than i am
i think i enjoy like sucking dick more
fingery stuff and you blowing your
finger in your butt i don't want
anything in there
never i like getting my ass eaten i
don't like a finger in my butt wait wait
wait wait wait tell me my buddy wait do
you [ __ ] more do you put the gel on it
before
cleanse he'll think it's the same thing
so funny you are wearing a bus stop like
fruits toss this for a salad yeah tell
us what's up
called right we're working on both parts
we're getting about
[ __ ] rings the whole thing oh wow i
can't wait okay you know what we're
gonna wrap up the show because i'm just
that's what i know what to say we have
some rapid fire questions so the first
thing that comes to your mind okay go
ahead and say it all right what's the
worst thing you've ever done to attract
someone you've had a crush on the worst
like the thirstiest it could be what
yeah or just cringy like i know i looked
up a guy's like spotify playlist just
know what music oh i feel like oh i
really love his band and then he's
asking me questions i've pretended to be
willing to go camping that's to work
i will never no matter how much i like
someone will never go camping not
happening i pretended to be willing to
well i didn't go camping okay good oh my
god
yeah probably something like that or
just like have you ever like
texted someone and then was like oops
sorry wrong number oh no i didn't
remember when i called that guy and hung
up and then he called me back and i was
like that's so weird
well rayna told me she did that and she
tried to lie to me
beyond that the audacity we were sitting
in this cafe in nashville and she was
like i accidentally called him i said
[ __ ] you did not i don't tell you
you she cannot lie to me she tries like
one supporter
it is so true like i can't lie to her
about anything like one time she was
like looking at me look at my phone i
was like smiling this guy sent me this
thing she's like what are you looking at
and i was like um i don't um i don't
like i can't light her she's actually
should have been a detective and i love
them
i have a face like i can i have the
right yeah
like that's my well like if i wasn't
doing this i would want to be like a pi
or like someone that like interrogates
yeah i think that seems so fun so it
goes without saying like i'm not a liar
like real stuff i don't lie about like
white lives
we get along really well and our
business is so fun though
i'm very much injured i think it's okay
to lie sometimes it's like i feel like
i'm just a girl i feel like no but i'm
just so much really i'm just really good
at it i feel like i lie about it i'm
late i'm always like the traffic is bad
it's like no i i was i was still getting
ready at the time i was happy i believe
my own lies like i've said something to
someone they're like
oh yeah wait i convinced myself that
it's the truth like wait i feel like it
does it count as a lie if you like
believe me okay next question is so
funny
okay guys can girls genuinely be friends
100 truly
thousand percent i mean maybe i'm just
like not hot enough but none of my guy
friends want to [ __ ] me but like i have
always had like
best best guy friends
if you have sex with them first
then you can be friends with does that
count no um i i'm trying to think if i
have any guy friends i haven't sex with
i do um
yeah i think that they can i think as
you get older it also gets more it's
probably it gets easier like i think the
stakes are a little higher as you get
older i'm not sleeping with people i
wouldn't date we did a whole episode on
this too yeah yeah i like i go go off
about it because i'm like oh come on
like we're yes right you know we're
adults like yes
if a guy said we think it's a red flag
if a guy says guys and girls can't be
friends it's like oh you just can't be
around a woman without trying to [ __ ]
here
okay what's the worst thing that's ever
happened to you during a makeout i'll
give you mine for example i've had two
separate guys on two separate occasions
have a nosebleed on me go speed on them
i didn't know split on them they know
split oh they but they blow spot on you
i don't know why that was you that did
that gross other than that
i can t i feel like do you know mine or
do i know yours
that's friendship i'm trying to think if
anything bad ever happened like no one's
ever like head-butted me started
bleeding thrown throw up like i mean i'm
somebody's crapping into your mouth oh
yeah that's pretty bad well i was making
out this guy this was remember that
summer my lips were so chapped
um like that i was just like oh my gosh
like i have chronic chapped lips and i
just it's fine now but i was making out
and it started to become so painful he
was also a bad kisser he's like my
mustache her beard was rubbing up again
so i just had to like literally be like
i feel nauseous but and he was like do
you need to leave but they came here
no they just felt so like chapped yeah
you know what i mean and a beard
mustache hurts it was like all it was it
was really painful
it's always awkward to tell someone you
want them to leave right yeah right
you know what i've done one time is i
set an alarm on my phone for two minutes
from now and i changed the ringer to
sound like a phone call and i'm like
it's my dad i got it it's like we fell
down the stairs and they right here it's
your dad they're like so you set an
alarm and you make wait wait your meetup
you made out for two minutes no no
listen listen listen we're making out
he's like i'll be right back leaves the
room why do you set an alarm i don't
know where you went set an alarm for two
minutes from now that sounds like a
phone call coming in so when he comes
back in phone starts ringing
oh okay and you know that's what i said
and i see snooze on the phones right
anybody's ever had like really bad
breath or something
oh that's nothing comes to mind honestly
pretty good that's good yeah awesome i
mean i've had really bad other stuff
happen i was giving this guy a [ __ ]
and he was butt naked standing up in my
living room like [ __ ] my face and he
stopped no not the prostitute
sorry for another literally sitting in
the same place um no this is somebody
else um and he stopped the [ __ ] for a
second picked up his hat and put it on
oh yeah naked standing in my living room
backwards backwards picked it up and put
it on backwards
just because he felt like it was hotter
he just said it felt like the move i was
like i i you i mean ashley and i will
roast somebody that's like american
psycho stuff done if you play backwards
on you
but it's like his merch he's like i just
want you to be wearing my merch he's
like look at me
he's like if i could pretend you're a
guy this would be great that is so funny
next time someone's eating my [ __ ] i'm
just gonna put this hat on
be like you need to represent it while
you're down there that's hysterical
i love it okay youngest or oldest you
would date
date or sleep with yes 18 18 sleep
legal eighteen two call what yeah sleep
with yeah sure i sleep with
literally legal all right like is that
the oldest i mean i've always dated the
oldest i mean
if i find you attractive like i'm
typically not attracted to older men and
older looking men like i've always dated
younger guys and um my joke is like am i
like am i going to be
45 and think 45 year old guys are
attractive are you still going to think
so
it'll click eventually but um
no i mean i
i don't think i'm going to be attracted
to an 18 year old but like if i am let's
do this and i don't know i don't think
i'm going to be attracted to a 60 year
old but if i am yeah i'm down all right
um everybody i've ever dated really
seriously has been exactly my age that's
like my perfect like i i don't need
somebody 15 years older than me i don't
need money from like an older guy
ashley's like the oldest and youngest is
18.
18 18 to 60
is my hinge um but sleeping with i slept
with one guy who's 10 years younger than
me but that's not my norm um
worse or better does age give you
experience rain and i've had pretty good
experience i there was a period where
like i'd slept with three guys in a row
slept with casually dated that were all
10 years younger than me they're trying
to impress you because you're older than
them i just think there's more knowledge
today yeah
like we're telling men like it's your
job to get women off you need to find
the clay totally [ __ ] a little bit
foreplay like i think there's so much
out there today explaining to men
yeah people with penises like how to do
this
both for [ __ ] these two young guys
they were like friends and they had like
made it a point to
to figure out how to pleasure a woman
remember that like really it was really
nice like it didn't work out with them
but like they they were like i wanted to
tweet
these millennials they were like 26 and
they were like we want to figure this
out
yeah yeah they're learning good lessons
very young
yeah all right
last question the big daddy
give yourselves a housewives slogan
goddamn it i know the other day i hate
this question when i get it cause i'm
like oh
i know because we love housewives we're
like big obsessed i watch every single
one watch every episode of wait do you
guys watch housewives in new york girl
yeah we have um
yeah i thought i was coming here oh i
gotta say i stopped watching that one
leah's like the only redeemable part of
that
don't you like kate kennedy does these
and she's so funny about him you like
she like spins around in her chair and
does like a whole stop she has like a
whole entire thing so maybe mine's like
on brand maybe it's like
maybe it's like
you know what they say girls got to eat
and guys got to eat too
this ass
i don't know
i know i was thinking about like
incorporating girls gotta eat like you
guys you guys know i'll do anything
because the girls got to
cute
try to kind of just plug the business
basically yeah yeah yeah at any moment
okay well plug all your stuff right now
plug where they can find the podcast the
tour the merch everything well the new
company it's vibes only it launches on
six six sex x um we're so proud of it
and we've worked on an entire year on
this and um so that is going to be
available on six six it's vibes only dot
com that's the instagram we're gonna
have a twitter i don't know if it'll be
live by then it will be uh i'm on it
she's on it um
we're [ __ ] doing it we think we have
the best sex toys in the entire world
yes and then again they're just going to
get better this is not it that there's a
whole nother part coming but we kind of
want to make sure people get them in
hand so first wave before we announce
the rest of it um and of course listen
to girls gotta eat wherever you guys
find podcasts i love it i love it you
guys the fact that you're here
really is giving sophia and i just like
we're shaking
you guys we look so special awesome we
looked up to you as podcasters yeah i
love all your content we've been
following you for forever so thank you
so much for coming thank you honestly
thank you thank you
and thank you guys for watching we will
see you next tuesday bye
[Music]
you